face à la multiplication des exactions
de la russie l'assemblée générale des
nations unies a été appelé à voter une
proposition soumise par les états unis
elle a approuvé la suspension de la
russie du conseil des droits de l'homme
mon programme est très simple il ne
contient que trois éléments ce sont des
armes des armes et des armes je rappelle
que dans ce document d'istanbul
les ukrainiens ont clairement déclaré
que les futurs garanties de sécurité
pour l'ukraine ne s'appliquerait pas à
la crimée à sébastopol dans le projet
d'hyères cette déclaration claire est
absente vision de l'auteur nous voyons
cela comme une manifestation du fait que
le régime de kiev est contrôlé par
washington et ses alliés pousse le
président zelensky à poursuivre les
hostilités la république tchèque est le
premier pays de l'otan a livré des chars
de combat à l'ukraine il n'a aucun
scrupule à écraser ce qu'il considère
comme une menace nous ce n'est pas
nouveau
personne
n'aurait pas prédit il ya cinq ans sa
manière de jouer le tout pour le tout la
russie elle continue de nier les
massacres de bitche à hier l'ambassade
de russie en france a relayé cette photo
sur twitter on y voit une rue de bou cha
et des reporters de guerre en plein
chaos de prendre en photo un chat le
tweet retiré depuis a provoqué la colère
des autorités françaises jean yves le
drian a réagi ce matin la russie
manifestement utilisent cette propagande
donc je crois que jean yves le drian est
la bonne décision le courage de
convoquer l'ambassadeur de russie le
président de la république nous a
demandé d'envoyer avec le garde des
sceaux des gendarmes et des magistrats
en ukraine qui vont pouvoir aider nos
amis ukrainiens a constaté les massacres
qui ont eu lieu en ce qui concerne
l'ukraine arrêtez arrêtez purement et
simplement de sa privée de
s'approvisionner pardon en gaz russe il
faut le faire maintenant il faut arrêter
avec ces espèces de gens incompétents
qui ne savent pas de quoi ils parlent
la réalité c'est que jamais on n'a
autant augmenter les achats de gaz payé
en monnaie forte en euros à la russie
est ce que vous imaginez qu'un jour
monsieur lavrov monsieur peskov monsieur
poutine lui-même soit arrêté et amené
dans une cellule à la haye le principal
coupable porte désormais un visage celui
de has had bec au bourg baeckeoffe
surnommé le boucher de butch aujourd'hui
on doit faire tout pour que ça c'est
impossible parce que on doit qu'à qui
plombe la décision comme ça dans
l'europe d'aujourd'hui elle doit être
responsable pour cet acte je men elle
selon le site d'activistes ukrainien une
forme napalm ce lieutenant koné qui
serait à la tête de l'unité qui
traversait la ville au moment où les
exécutions ont été commises pendant ce
temps les sanctions continuent à tomber
contre moscow oui et notamment contre
des proches de vladimir poutine des
mesures ont été prises à l'encontre de
ses deux filles je sais que certains ne
votent plus et ça me fend le coeur j'ai
tellement envie de leur dire mais
utilisez votre bulletin de vote pour
vous donner de la force et pour me
donner de la force donner de la force
aux idées dont j'étais que j'étais le
seul à défendre le président poutine et
les oligarques russes dissimulent des
actifs et des ressources sur les comptes
bancaires des membres de leur famille il
s'agissait donc d'un effort pour
atteindre ces actifs et c'est pourquoi
ces personnes ont été sanctionnées vous
maintenez qu emmanuel macron est un
petit dictateur à je maintiens qu
emmanuel macron est un homme dangereux
est ce que vous mettez ce petit
dictateur c'est une expression dans un
métier si on croit que le futur
président de la république quels qu'ils
soient va nous protéger c'est perdu
d'avancé
la réalité c'est que la situation va
s'aggraver si on les laisse aux manettes
ces gens là c'est sûr il ni petit ni
grand c'est une vie voiture en tout cas
c'est un petit bonheur donc voronov trop
dure pas